hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the killings
in all this starts now if you're astute
you'll notice that something um is
different I'm not playing the study of
insanity that's very true yes indeed and
it's because the game became irreparably
bugged I there was nothing that could be
done it was fixed it was not to be fixed
it was broken beyond repair
fine to uninstall the game reinstall it
I'll just never be able to play the
Wonder that was that custom story but
I've heard that this one is also very
good so let's go yes interesting hmm I
hope everybody's No Shave November is
going well as you can see my moustache
is bloomed hello
thief Nuka hmm hello Kevin for one free
[Music]
measuring measuring what I'm not quite
sure present
thank Bank killings in arms start now
this is a full conversion custom story
meaning that it has new environments it
has new entities it has could possibly
have new monsters I don't know what to
expect from this because I actually
haven't seen much in terms of this mod
oh the black I can't even go that way
mmm yes nice Castle this is indeed very
very very detailed I like it I like it a
lot
well it seems to be enough here huh
hello well I'm not here at the moment
but I've hidden the key at the appointed
position ah you daft bastard
like I remember where that a pointed oh
there it is ha ha ha ha smashing hmm I
must have arrived in old stuff this is
the inn
very interesting I haven't no I'm tired
in this journey I should take a nap in
my room to the right well screw you I do
what I please
see ya locked I wait is that my room
who's this door locked as well fine
I will retire to the boudoir but not
before a little exploring
huh these closets are mysteriously
locked lock just like everything else oh
I suppose I shall retire now
how long am I gonna keep up that
Oh things took a turn for the worst very
very quickly
Oh Oh No
Oh Kent what the hell is this Baylor's
oh yeah that said suppose you'd currency
that was bull diamond nope
come and get me you foul Beast I suppose
he's going to be backing down the door
any minute now
huh oh yes you wish to fight come out to
me Bravo
yes friend be you friend or enemy are
you I don't know where you're coming
from the audio it's not cluing me in no
not there are you Julius oh don't tell
yourself let's see yeah oh just standing
there haha
oh crap houston moving away kind of fool
am i huh I've ruined my chances of
escape oh no I have not this blood come
from
oh no I'm I don't know who I am anymore
hmm yes it seems open ah
you fiend I'm dead
Oh Earl arrived today he's the guy
Johannes told me about he will stay here
for a while no one knows how long but I
hope it's not too long he's asleep his
job is to investigate the killing that
happened in Alstott I hope he won't find
any references and leave soon
um this is another Lantern what got hell
Oh God where do I go wait a minute what
hey use it to prove er well poof you I
mean well poof you I'll just take my
failures and be on my way
harem harem hold up my glorious
moustache is falling apart I don't know
what's going on it's totally natural by
the way hmm maybe that key I have is
more sailors enjoyable indeed haha
locked all right
coins to pay Boris Boris is this made by
the same guy that made that other one
tenebrous Lake was it oh then we're in
for a treat my friends we are in for a
quality ride through the gun from the
darkness that is the killings in all the
stuff I didn't know that it was by the
same guy I just got it through download
link
you know Boris from the Easter Egg ha ha
[Music]
my moustache is not falling off
that's ridiculous oh I just decided to
play like this now ah Taylor's house how
nobly enjoyable well now that we're
perfectly perfectly normal here there
anything behind here no okay I can't
grow a glorious moustache I can't and
the glue on this piece of crap fell off
a long time ago this is just tape I
can't grow a glorious moustache I'm
pitiful pitiful a crowbar hey bugs I was
supposed to buy that I thought that was
gonna be requisite of the crowbar
baloney you found out for the fool that
I am I can still keep the accent
knowledge the same without the glories I
saw oh god I looked at the thing I
didn't know oh god you can see laughing
ha ha oh man did you see what happened
there I'll break it down for you though
for those who didn't get what was
happening I kept looking back to see if
something was there and there was
nothing apparently but then I looked
down and there was something on the
ground there and as soon as I looked
oh that was beautiful just beautiful
what you did there was amazing I can't
believe that
Oh God okay yeah right I knew I knew
that this is gonna be good cuz if you
haven't seen tenebrous lake yet crm I
haven't even used my lantern what am i
doing
whoa this is a different Lantern I was
like will light your way man that is
totally cool that's totally bang you're
not a pooper are you hiding out of over
what the hell ah
no kidding it alerted the monsters good
God what come on
be quick and whatever you're doing he's
not behind me anymore is it
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
did I get it oh boy
[Music]
all right
yes I don't know where I'll post a
chance to build what I need you do not
have nothing for people did you know
that you could find as much money around
here cool that's awesome yeah okay bye
man this custom story is awesome I mean
this custom story is oh no no my power
all alone in the dungeon no I really
like this new landing it's much more
atmospheric forward go over there
[Music]
oh no oh god this horrifying discussion
Tori is unbelievable man this is the
best the best I've ever played
oh but I'm a lot of time for now so I'm
a little time and so thank you all so
much for watching let me know what you
think of this custom story in the
comments below and check the annotations
for more videos that I've done in the
past and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]